Ok!
We're in Sweden for Christmas!
I got-
I'm so excited because we found a bunch of infaltabel suits bluberry ones
Swedish snacks that I haven't had in forever.
Lussekatter! (Saffron bun)
Oh My God!
I want to have one now
And when I saw it, I just lit up
Cause we eat this during Christmas
They're so good
Oh My God
I used to eat these for breakfast
It's not good, but-
We have- We're in Sweden
For Christmas and then me, my family
And you guys are coming along
For this vlog
Excuse me while I- *arrrhmhr*
Hey Marzia fuck you
I dare you to get that Snickers *snickers*
That Snickers is damned
Well, we forgot our luggage...
At the airport
I don't know how we managed to do that
I'm so tired
We have to go back all the way
I feel so stupid
I can't believe we forgot the luggage
I'm too tired to deal with this right now
I'm just like-
Here we go again
Back again
At the airport
*Disappointed*
It's all closed
Well well well
Fucks sake. *Laugh*
We're in Stockholm with no luggage.
I'm so tired.
I'm gonna have to go early tomorrow.
Is the hotel even open?
Hello?
*Beepboopbeepboopbeepboop*
It's so late
*boompf*
Bleh
Good morning! I got my luggage.
I'm so happy I got it.
Marzia would've killed me, seriously
We got the bag with all the gifts
Going to meet my parents now
I don't know if you've seen them
In a video before, but you will today.
That's exciting!
I'm also getting a... tattoo today.
I managed to book,
From an artist I really like,
While I was here in Sweden.
So I'm really excited for that as well.
So today should be a very fun day!
Alright, so I'm here with my familyyyy!
We have my mom!
Beautiful mother, mommypie-
Mommypie: Hey!
My beautiful sister, Fanny-
-and daddy! heyy
We're all having Christmas breakfast
And I just ate too much
Oh by the way, this is my
Niece?
Nephew?
Nephew!
[Arnold!]
Arnold, I'm an uncle.
Hey Arnold! :D
Felix:Heyyy             Fanny:Wheeee
So cute! (/w\*)
Say hi to the camera
Do we look alike? Not really
*laughs*
Yeah, you do. He looks so cute. (You want to say hi?)
He looks so scared of me.
I'm sorry, Arnold schwarzenegger
*laughs*
So this is Ynk
You guys remember- If you watch me a long time ago
You'll recognize Ynk
She's quite the character, *laughs* so cute
And this is Puma. She loves me
Ok, so now we're going to get the tattoo and get high as a kite
And my- my parents are getting one too!
*laughs and cheers* yeah finally!
Surprise!
Christmas Gift!
Alright, it's got the stencil on
Looking very nice
I'm really happy with how it looks
I'm excited
🎵🎵🎵
I've got the lines done I'm not looking Marzia: Wowww
*laughs*
It's pretty cool
My left right butt cheek fell asleep
It's really weird
🎵🎵🎵
Alright! You can peek now. [Do you like it?]
I love it!
Look at my dad's face he's like
（＊〇□〇）……！
That's so cool! [Hey you like it?]
I love it [awesome]
That's awesome
So cool
The detail is amazing
I wonder where all that dotting you were doing was
I was like that's cool
It looks way better in person
So you like it now?
I love it!
I really like it
What do you mean now?
*ow owh rouw rouw rouwf*
*laughs*
I don't know if my dad liked it but
I really love it
I'm so happy with it
I  just love getting tattooed
Like I know a lot of people have opinions about it
but for me it's such a great experience
[Yeah!]
I'm always
it was really cool
It's such a great experience
I just-
I'm so thrilled I got to do it while I'm here
I think my dad will like it eventually
*laughs*
Umm yeah we're just going to get some lunch then
It's nice
It's nice to be in my home territory
Feel good
Feel Swedish
Okay. So
Let's see
Mommypie's reaction to the tattoo
There it is [*woah*]
It's kinda wrapped though so you can't really see it
It's a church?
It’s the Swedish church (OH)
[swedish]
I like it!
Do you like it?
Yeah!
Is the roof kinda opened?
Yeah it's a guy peeking out
Ohh *laughs*
That's what scared dad he was like
（＊〇□〇）……！
Is it the church from [place name]?
No it's the church from [place name]
Oh it is? Yeah
There's blood
Yeah, it’s fine
Now it's your turn mom
Ya? Yea
I'll do the same
Should I take my shirt off?
Ok cut
Aw you got me a gift!
Ok thank you mom
Thank you give me my gift
YES!! *laughs*
*dun dun dun dun dun dun dun*
What just happened *laughs*
It's present time!
[WHOOO]
What did you get Marzia?
'Merry Christmas' aw 'we love you' aww
That's so sweet
Oh did you see the card? It's [inaudible]
Yeah
[Whooo what is it]
Just open it
OOOooohhhhh
But you know it's the first one
Oh! *laughs* [yeah]
Ahh yay
What is it? What is it?
I can't wait
It's very- *laughs*
This is the worst
Thank you so much
Oooohhh [Ooh it's so cool]
It’s so cute!
I love it!
Omg! It’s amazing!
Thank you so much!
Oh? *laughs*
Nintendo 64
You shouldn't have gotten me something [Nawww]
Aww
You don't even know what it is
I know
You do??
There's nothing
Yeah *laughs* It's not true (ooh)
OOOOH
OHHH It's a ??
Aww thank you
It's a t-shirt?
Thank you
It's super cool
I really like it
Thank you so much
*Thank yous and hugs all around* :3
🎵🎵🎵
So now we are going to Gamla Stan
Which is the  the old part of Stockholm
to look at the Christmas stuff
Yayyyy [Yayyyy] :D
Do you like Stockholm? [I lovee Stockholm]
Ooh wow
So now
We're looking for the alleyway that's like super narrow
I remember going as a kid
I thought it was really cool
So I wonder now
If I will still be impressed by this alleyway
Alright here it is
This is the alleyway
Oooh that’s creepy
(It’s nice!) It’s nice?
Welcome
To 'Pewdiepie walks down an alleyway'
This is my- if I do an album this is my cover
Great. That's... lovely
But you gotta look dead inside
*laughs*
Someone else is coming what do I do?
*heheheh*
It's one way back
*heheh* *ugh*
I can't do it
This is cool
It's not that- it's not like crazy
I don't feel like claustrophobic or anything
~Felix's ASMR~
Ok, that was a really fun day
I gotta clean this
Jesus that's disgusting
MmmMM
Look at it
It's amazing
I'm so happy with it
I'm jealous
Yeah? Yea
Tomorrow is Christmas Eve
In Sweden we celebrate on the 24th
And uh-
I'll film some bits
So let's go to that
'god Jul'
Merry Christmas as we say in Sweden
Today we celebrate Christmas it's the 24th
And we're getting the-
We're going to my sister's house to celebrate
I don’t know how much I’ll vlog of it
But I got doggy
You're putting on the seat belt for me?
Thanks dad! [You're vlogging!]
I'm vlogging
God Jul
So this is what my dad makes every Christmas
It's m- It's potato grat-gratening? (Potatis Gratäng)
What is it called? *laughs*
Na, there's no way that's what it's called
It's the best! The potato gre-tain. (Oh really Poods?)
Kill that woman
Ok
I'm so excited for all the Swedish food
This is the part of Christmas
That really matter
Screw friendship, family and kindness
Gimme the food!
🎵🎵🎵
Alright we're going for a little Christmas walk
I didn't really log anything at all today
But it's been a really nice Christmas
I'm so full. I ate so much food
It's the best
Um yeah. I'll just see you tomorrow
Really this is a shit day to vlog
And god Jul and there's a tree everybody
There's a tree
Oh my gawd
Oh look at the snow
It's snow- Oh My God it's snow!
OH
Oh it's-
Ewhh
Hey Marzia
*throws snowball*
Got 'em
*laughs*
Okay we're leaving now mom bye
My mom is trying to get us to
Get all the food
And I can't eat anything else
Mom stop [Marzia laughs]
It's time to stop we're leaving
Byeeee
Do I look tired?
It's- guess what time it is
Eight o'clock
*laughs*
It's a really nice Christmas
Did you enjoy yourself Marzia?
IIIII... Did
And she loved it
*AHHHH*
We are back home in Sweden (Uh what)
I wanted to check out my taters
Oh yeahh! I'm so happy with it
Uh the tattoo artist did such a great job
It's the church where I grew up during summer
And my sister actually got married in the church as well and
I wanted for a long time a tattoo that
That’s not necessarily about heritage or where I’m from
It’s more about just commemorating
My past life in a way if that makes any sense
Umm
I spent 21 years in Sweden
And then as soon as YouTube hit it off
I just left you know and I never came back.
21 years of my life and
I have you know obviously a lot of great memories and
I always look back on how my life could be so different
And
*sighs*
It's an amazing thing really where Youtube has taken me
But I still love where I'm from
And I love my family
And I love Sweden and uh-
I’m so glad I did this visit
Because it was so nice to meet my family and
And just be Swedish for a while
You're probably watching this a lot later
But if you-  yeah I hope you
Had a great time with your family and friends during Christmas
Or whatever you did
I don't care
BLARGH